Amen.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
four verses that were revealed
very far apart.
The first two verses that we're going to
hear were revealed the first night the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
appointed as a prophet. The second two
verses we're going to hear are verses
that were revealed
just prior to
the most difficult times of Mecca
which ultimately culminated in the hijra
of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam from Mecca to Medina which was
a very difficult time for our prophet
and our brothers and sisters from
amongst the Muslim. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says
[Silence]
Allah describes himself as the one who
taught by the pen or the one who marked
by the pen which that is a a dual
meaning which this chapter has a lot of
dual meanings. Two things that are meant
at the exact same time by one statement.
Right? sometimes this is referred to
in English as a double antandra.
However, sometimes a double entandra
most of the time or a lot of time in
English has a kind of u comedic and
often times vulgar undertone to it.
When we say it's a it's it's a double
entandra. Usually it's used in the world
of satire. But it is a
dual meaning just we had the dual
meaning with the first word of this
chapter
which could mean recite and also means
read something that's written. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala could have chosen a
word that meant one of the two and then
there would be no no second meaning.
However, it's intentional that it is
chosen to have two meanings at the same
time. And the Quran is full of this. As
a matter of fact, this is extremely
common in the Quran to the point that
some words have up to seven and eight
meanings. The word
has 14 meanings in the Arabic language.
All of them are intended by this word.
the word
has seven meanings in the Arabic
language and all of those seven meanings
are intended by that one word. We see
the pattern here. So there are a lot of
words and this is one of the big
difficulties of translation. When you
translate, you have to stick with what
you have to choose one of those
meanings. You can't choose all of them.
Otherwise, it breaks down the structure
of what you're translating. And so, you
can start to kind of see how much is
lost in translation and how important
the Arabic language is in understanding
the Quran, the words of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. And so Allah chose the word
which was to mean recite and it was to
mean read. Both of them are intended
based on who is reading this verse or
who is listening to it. Likewise, the
statement of Allah,
he is the one
who taught by way of the pen and also
means the one who marked and left an
impression by the pen. What does that
mean? Marked and left an impression by
the pen.
So
some companions came from Yemen in the
prophet's time when he was in Medina
and they traveled all the way to him.
They heard about him. They accepted
Islam and they came to visit him. And
when they came to visit, they said,
they said, "Oh messenger of Allah, we
have come all this way to ask you about
what the first thing Allah created from
this existence."
Now notice the wording.
forch.
[Silence]
He said
they they came they said we came to ask
you about the first thing Allah created
from this existence. He said, "The first
thing Allah created was the pen."
And he said to it, "Write." And the pen
responded, "What shall I write?" He
said, "Write all that is to be until the
day of resurrection, until the day of
judgment." The prophet commented on this
and said, "And that happened 50,000
years before the creation of the heavens
and the earth." So we mentioned before
that in the Arabic language
comes from the root word al
which is to leave a mark on something or
to leave an impression on something.
If the meaning here is to mark something
down or leave an impression, then what
is meant by he left an impression using
the pen, meaning the preserved tablet
that he wrote 50,000 years before the
first creation. Every word that I'm
saying right now, every thought that's
going through your mind, every beat of
my heart, every drop of sweat, every
molecule and cell in my body or yours,
everything
has been documented by Allah 50,000
years before the creation. Can you
imagine? Actually, you can't imagine.
How can something that be imagined?
It's not just the macro things. Every
tiny detail, everything, everything
was written by Allah 50,000 years before
the first creation.
That is that writing came from where?
Where did the information for that pen
to write come from? It came from the
knowledge of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala knows all
that was and all that is and all that
would be and all that would have been
had things been subhanahu wa ta'ala
these are the stages of decree these are
ref referred to as
are four there are four stages of
decree. Meaning everything that exists
goes through four stages in order to
come into existence. Everything good and
bad.
Everything that is great and small.
Everything good and bad. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala he is the creator of
everything whether it's good or bad. And
so the first stage
is
the eternal knowledge of Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then
translated that knowledge into the pen.
The second stage of decree which is he
wrote all that was to be subhanahu wa
ta'ala from that knowledge.
Okay. So we already know that the
preserved tablet that is mentioned in
the Quran
it's also referred to as
the reference or the mother of all books
right that preserved tablet
it is preserved from change it doesn't
change
nothing that is written when allah law
wrote it 50,000 years before the first
creation
was ever changed. Not one dot, not one
t, not anything, not one period, not one
addition or subtraction was made. That
is why it is referred to as the preserve
tablet.
And so that what is written in the
preserved tablet is preserved. It will
never change. But does that mean that
Allah forced
the outcome of what is in that tablet?
No. It just means that he knew what was
going to happen and he wrote it. But
writing something doesn't mean that he
forced it to happen or compelled anyone
to make a decision. And so our free will
works within the confines of those
options.
This is a concept that a lot of people
have a hard time understanding which is
how do we balance free will
with
the decree of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and major innovations were introduced
into Islam
and the second innovation ever
introduced into Islam still in the time
of the companions
was the innovation of alad
decree that some people from amongst the
Muslim went so far in believing in the
decree of Allah that they negated free
will and said free will is just a a form
of it is just a figure of speech it
doesn't really exist this is referred to
as el jaba
which is to be forced comp compulsion
then there was another group which went
the exact opposite all the way in the
opposite of that which were which was
they believed in free will so much that
they
rejected the notion of decree that Allah
wrote anything. As a matter of fact,
some of the of the extremist of the in
the time of the companions in Iraq,
they went so far as to say Allah doesn't
even know that we exist.
Can you imagine that?
Subhanal.
went so far in believing in in free
will that they said we are a kind of
accident and a byproduct of Allah's
first creation and he is unaware of our
existence
and this group was around in the time of
the companions the very tail end of the
companions
and so extremism breeds an extreme
response always when you see an extreme
thought
it is responded to with extremism. This
is how humans are which is one of the
miracles of Islam and the Quran is that
we are given
we are given balance
and we walk the middle path between all
extremes in Islam.
And so what is the balance here between
free will and decree?
We have free will but it is not
unlimited free will because unlimited
free will would mean that we are able to
create our own options. That's not the
case. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
made a creation for us and we exist
within a set of rules
and we can make decisions
confined to those general set of rules.
If you imagine with me for instance a
game of chess right there are many
pieces and each piece moves in a
different way. Don't understand this as
Ali is saying chess is halal or haram.
That's not what we're discussing right
now. So if we look at the game of chess,
we say I as a player at this table can
make as many decisions and as freely as
I choose,
but only within the confines of what?
Within the confines of the rules of that
game. I can move these pieces outside of
the rules of that game, but I'm not
playing chess anymore at that point. So
Allah created for us a creation and he
gave us free choice within that
creation. However,
our choices are limited by the
limitations of our creation. Understood?
So the first two levels or stages of
decree in order for me to come into
existence or you we went through these
four stages. We were first in the ex ex
in the u in the infinite knowledge of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala the eternal
knowledge of Allah and then Allah wrote
that we were to come into existence.
The third stage is
also
to come into existence.
You all do not will something until
Allah wills it first. Correct? And so in
order for anything to come into
existence, it comes into existence by
the will of Allah. Is anything happen
against Allah's will? Absolutely not.
Absolutely not. Never. Nothing will ever
come to an existence or exist without
Allah willing it first. He wills for it
to come into existence.
The fourth and final stage is creation
means that Allah created it. Allah
he tells us in
elsewhere he says Allah is the creator
of all that exists. Everything
everything that exists Allah is its
creator. Meaning everything that is
created he is the creator of it.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so in order for me to come into
existence or you or any one of us, it is
in the knowledge of Allah. He then wrote
it in that preserved tablet. He then
willed for it to happen and allowed it
to happen. And then he subhanahu wa
ta'ala created it.
These are the stages of decree. If you
understand this, you will have a much
more sound understanding of how the
decree of Allah subhanahu wa tala is in
relation to free will. It is free will,
but it is not unlimited free will. We
choose based on the confines of the game
that we're playing, right? as the
example we gave
this here is one of the meanings of the
statement of Allah.
So everything that he taught the human
being he first marked down and impressed
upon the preserved tablet.
we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
benefit us to teach us to enlighten us.
We ask him subhanahu wa ta'ala to grant
us understanding of the secrets and the
and the the clear and ambiguous of
his book and the sunnah of his prophet
Samuhammed
just a reminder to everyone One,
tomorrow is J. The prophet Sam
tells us that
he said the most beloved to Allah
throughout the week is the salah of in
the masid on the morning of J. So if you
don't usually come to fud and you were
to choose one and a place to start start
with the morning of fud.